[Música]
ya lo decíamos hoy en directo vamos a
Lima la capital peruana luego de que la
fiscalía de ese país pidiera 18 meses de
prisión preventiva para la ex jefa de
gabinete Betsy Chávez y para los
exministros del interior y turismo Willy
Huerta y Roberto Sánchez respectivamente
todos ellos son requeridos por presunta
participación en lo que el actual
gobierno califica de fallido autogolpe
de estado del expresidente Pedro
Castillo conectamos con Francisco
Zacarías corresponsal de France 24
Francisco En qué se basa la fiscalía
para solicitar esos 18 meses de prisión
preventiva
Buenas noches una fuente del Ministerio
Público me ha afirmado que la fiscalía
tiene un sólido caso que se sustenta en
pruebas y testimonios que comprometen
seriamente al ex primer ministra de
Betsy Chávez en la comisión de los
presuntos delitos de Conspiración y
rebelión al supuestamente haber
participado en el fallido intento de
golpe de estado del expresidente Pedro
Castillo el 7 de diciembre de 2022
pruebas y vídeos así como testimonios de
Testigos acusan seriamente a Betsy
Chávez de conocer y coordinar las
acciones del expresidente Pedro Castillo
para cerrar el congreso de Perú y romper
el orden constitucional la ex primer
ministra Chávez ha negado en todo
momento haber cometido algún delito de
este tipo ante las autoridades peruanas
pero la segunda fiscalía Suprema
transitoria especializada en delitos
cometidos con funcionarios ha ordenado
la privación de su libertad Porque
además considera que existe un alto
peligro de fuga de la ex funcionaria de
este país Francisco cómo avanza el
proceso del expresidente Pedro Castillo
que tiene que cumplir estos 36 meses de
cárcel mientras es investigado por la
justicia
Bueno le cuento que Pedro Castillo lleva
ya casi cuatro meses privado de su
libertad mientras la fiscalía realiza
las indagaciones le cierra el cerco al
entorno más cercano del ex gobernante
para conseguir más pruebas y en realidad
las cosas no le están yendo del todo
bien a Pedro Castillo porque la segunda
sala penal permanente de la Corte
Suprema ha rechazado una apelación que
buscaba anular la investigación que
realiza la fiscalía por
el fallido intento de golpe de estado
sin embargo los abogados de Pedro
Castillo trabajan en dos frentes
localmente cruzan los dedos porque una
corte acepte un recurso de aguas Corpus
que ordene su libertad y anule la
sentencia de prisión preventiva Mientras
tanto en el frente externo la defensa de
Pedro Castillo espera y anhela que la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
respalde una denuncia donde se pide que
se le reponga en el cargo de presidente
de los peruanos las autoridades de este
país señalan que tienen pruebas de que
Pedro Castillo habría cometido una serie
de delitos sin embargo el ex gobernante
está dispuesto a jugarse el todo por el
todo por obtener su libertad la pregunta
que se hacen todos es Pedro Castillo
conseguirá su cometido bueno esa
respuesta sólo el tiempo lo